covin nineteen knb caractère pandémique
le 11 mars 2020 l'organisation mondiale
de la santé qualifié la propagation de
lakovic 19 de pandémie le virus était
alors présent dans environ 110 pays
mais la plupart des cas étaient recensés
en chine en iran ou en corée du sud avec
une augmentation fulgurante du nombre de
cas l'heure était au confinement le 13
mars
québec annoncé la fermeture de tous les
établissements d'enseignement et
services de garde pendant une période de
deux semaines
c'était le début de ces rendez vous
quotidiens et des bilans journalier
différents intervenants de plus en plus
espacées a besoin d eau
les sorties se faisait rare les
interactions entre les citoyens aussi
bon nombre de pays annonçait la
fermeture de leurs frontières
le canada et les états unis vont
interdire temporairement tout passage
non essentiels à la frontière quelques
jours plus tard c'était au tour des
commerces et services non essentiels de
suspendre leurs activités
le québec doit mettre sur pause pendant
trois semaines une pause forcée qui
s'étirera pendant des semaines dans les
grandes villes
les rues étaient désertes tout comme
certaines tablettes dans les épiceries
et pendant qu'on restreignait
l'utilisation des équipements de
protection individuelle le virus se
propager à vitesse grand v dans les
résidences pour m
retour en classe reporter messages
contradictoires à propos du port du
masque définition des commerces dits
essentiels
les hésitations de la classe politique
ont généré bien des incompréhensions et
des frustrations
entre le mécontentement de certains et
les appréhensions des autres il faudra
plus que jamais se serrer les coudes
dans la tente d'un vaccin ou d'un
traitement et surtout à la proche d'une
seconde vague qui semble plus que jamais
inévitable